I don't really like tips it tips about
communicating well tips about writing
when I would prefer is a process that
transforms you so the tips take place
automatically I mean for instance very
often the tip is given when you're
speaking to a crowd vary the pace of
your speech vary the volume
well those those are two good things but
if they happen mechanically it gets to
be kind of boring
some people are encouraged when they're
coached at this point leave where you're
standing and walk over there and take a
pause well maybe that makes sense in
terms of how it's written at the end of
that paragraph you want to make a space
before the next paragraph but it doesn't
necessarily make sense in terms of how
you're talking and relating to the
people you're talking with that relating
to them should be the source of a pause
the source of moving because it comes
out of the thought press that process
I'm going through and it comes out of
the thought process I sense you're going
through have you understood that last
part so I'm now I'm thinking if you have
what's the next thing that I can tack on
to that that'll mean something to you
and if you haven't should i clarify it a
little more so there's a dynamic
relationship between us that leads to a
change in pace to a change in volume and
that kind of thing a tip is just an
intellectual ization of that which might
be okay to give somebody once they've
got the grounding in the ability to
connect you know it but it ought to come
out of the connection it shouldn't be a
checkbox that you take off so I really
don't like tips if I'm pressed really
hard there are three tips that I do kind
of follow probably it's a good idea to
follow these tips after you get used to
being connected to somebody
there are three things that I like to do
I call it the three rules of three so
the first rule is I try only to say
three important things when I talk to
people no more than three if you can see
if it's one thing that's maybe even
better but usually there's a lot to say
but I when I make notes on what I want
to talk about if I say I'm going on past
three to four and five I start
eliminating and we're seeing like fold
them into the other things because three
things are really all I can remember and
I don't work from notes when I talk to
people and I advise other people not to
I don't never read it because reading
just excommunicate to you it's not
communication its excommunication in my
view so I can't remember more than three
things and I don't think they can
remember more than three things so
what's the point of telling them stuff
they're not going to remember so I stick
this here that's rule number one of rule
three three things the second rule is if
I have a difficult thing to understand
is something I think it's not going to
be that easy to get I try to say it in
three different ways because I think if
they come in from different angles you
have a better chance of making a getting
a three-dimensional view of this
difficult ideas so I try to say it three
different ways and the third tip which I
always forget is that if if I have a
difficult thing that that's hard to get
I tried to say it three times through
the talk so that the first time you hear
it you start to get used to it the
second time it's familiar in the third
time you say oh yeah yeah right okay so
no I do follow those three tips but I
don't think I tell somebody you're going
to get up to talk here are three tips to
remember it's a process you got to get
transformed into being a better
communicator you got to go through steps
where it's like going to the gym only
it's a lot more fun than going to the
gym because it involves connecting with
another person and we're built to
connect with another person
in spite of the fact that we often avoid
it it actually is fun when we get into
that position so if we can get ourselves
transformed into liking connecting with
the audience we're talking to or writing
for then these tits will come will
happen automatically or finally we'll be
able to put them to work in terms of
that transform the way we have of
connecting it really feels good
[Music]
you